how many octaves can Sabrina Carpenter
sing it's such a funny question I've
worked with my vocal coach Eric vitro
since I was like 12. he's told me that I
have four to five I'm always really
really like adamant about taking care of
my voice and he's the best and I love
him so much shout out to Eric
how is
Google how is Sabrina Carpenter related
to Joey King how are we related we're
not I wish we were Joey's one of my best
friends but yeah not by Blood we're not
related although it's funny I'll never
forget one night we went to this
restaurant in Georgia and like literally
three people that night stopped us to
ask us if we were twins I kid you not we
looked nothing alike and and they were
just convinced they're like oh my gosh
you guys are the most beautiful twins
you've ever seen were like what my mom
and her mom were also there with us and
so there was like
what it was so funny what it was our
night and no one's ever said that since